[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my mandalorian season 2
boba fett video you want some good news
they just announced that boba fett will
be showing up during season two
officially so we'll break it all down
there's a bunch of easter eggs we even
got that teaser from season one
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a baby yoda merch giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your boba fett predictions for
season two on the video
so we'll just break this down top five
style starting with number five if you
didn't see the news it just broke
star wars cast tamira morrison as boba
fett for the mandalorian season 2. now
he's not the main villain that's still
going to be maf gideon
but you all remember the boba fett
teaser from the mandalorian episode 5
and the gunslinger as sort of a
post-credit scene
[Music]
a lot of us saw that and just assumed
that it was boba fett that they were
trying to tease because of the way the
spurs jangle the same way that boba
fett's boots jangled when he was walking
around during empire strikes back in
return of the jedi
now it's confirmed that was boba fett in
that post-credits scene
now the report that says he's showing up
during season 2 didn't say
which episode he would debut and only
that he would have a relatively minor
role
during season 2 with the possibility of
a bigger role in the mandalorian season
so it sounds like they're sort of
spinning up to bigger boba fett stuff in
the future
they didn't say whether or not they cast
him with the idea that they might also
do a boba fett
disney plus series as a spin-off of the
mandalorian but that's always possible
too the disney ceo
said that they did have multiple
mandalorian spin-offs in the works
one of those is an ahsoka tv series one
of those is this documentary series that
just premiered another one could be a
boba fett series
so if there's only gonna be a little bit
of boba fett during season two normally
i would say they'd save some kind of big
boba fett teaser for the season two
finale
but the way the mandalorian season one
structured its episodes there were a lot
of one-off adventures outside the
canonical ongoing baby yoda moff gideon
main story
so hopefully they're using him for
something big but it sounds like his
episode could appear anywhere during the
season
but number four the reason why it's
important that they got tamira morrison
to play adult boba fett
as most of you probably realize when you
were thinking about this is because boba
fett
is another clone of jango fett and
tamira morrison played django fett
during attack of the clones
served as the basis for all the clones
so if they ever did
live-action clones in the star wars
universe they would all
look like tamira morrison now daniel
logan played child boba fett during
attack of the clones
and this is what he looks like as an
adult he has worn a boba fett costume
since he grew up but it's still just
more accurate to cast tamira morris and
his boba fett if you're doing him live
action and they even went back and
dubbed his voice as boba fett into
return of the jedi and empire strikes
back whenever he
speaks after doing attack of the clone
so that the continuity makes a little
more sense
even though we know it's going to be him
under the helmet the thing about boba
fett is that he never took his helmet
off that eventually wound up inspiring
the future mandalorian storylines that
they wound up spinning out with them not
taking their helmets off
i know there's a lot of questions
because during the clone wars and star
wars rebels mandalorians take their
helmets off all the time
don't worry when we actually start
getting season 2 episodes i'll explain
what's going on with all those easter
eggs
they kind of did that same thing with
inserting people into continuity from
the prequels with anakin skywalker's
force ghost and return of the jedi
speaking of anakin skywalker too there's
also talk of hayden christensen
actually participating in the obi-wan
disney plus series in some way
when they first announced the ob1 series
i thought that it would be really cool
if they did something like that but i
never
expected them to try and do it because
you have to consider whether or not it
would be the scarred visage of darth
vader hayden christensen
underneath the mask or if it would be
anakin skywalker in obi-wan kenobi
memories or
flashbacks or some sort of force vision
but if they wind up confirming hayden
christensen then i'll do a new video
about that but that's kind of separate
from the boba fett news
number three the boba fett stuff is in
addition to the ahsoka tano stuff during
the mandalorian season two and usually i
would say everything is connected within
the season all the different characters
and story lines
but the way they structured the
mandalorian season one is that not all
the characters and story lines were
connected some of them were just
one-offs
and because the boba fett teaser was on
tatooine and the mando and baby yoda
were only there
for a stop off ahsoka's story the reason
why mando and baby yoda run into her
at least at first doesn't seem like it's
going to have a lot to do with this new
boba fett story
ahsoka is supposed to play a much bigger
role during season 2 than boba fett so
it's safe to assume that at some point
though that the narrative ahsoka's
future will become more intertwined with
baby yoda and the mando's story and then
that will sort of spill over and cross
over with the boba fett stuff
in fun fact dave filoni just did a big
interview for the clone wars finale
he revealed during that that he only
wrote and directed
one episode of the mandalorian season
two so my initial reaction after seeing
that
is that his episode would be the big
ahsoka episode
because of course dave filoni should
direct the ahsoka episode if it's gonna
be her big live-action debut
she is the character that's most
precious to him and if you're a big
ahsoka fan
he said there might be more
opportunities for animated ahsoka series
set after the clone wars finale even
though he said right now he's not
currently working on more animated star
wars series himself he said that his
work on the mandalorian was keeping him
so busy
he just didn't have time to start doing
another animated show right now
take that for what you will but if
you're wondering if ashley eckstein is
going to do more
ahsoka stuff at least ahsoka voice over
stuff it sounds like there are more
plans to use
animated ahsoka around the star wars
universe at some point
number two what is boba fett gonna be
doing when he shows up during
mandalorian season two
well based on the teaser from the
mandalorian episode five
he was still on tatooine it's five years
after return of the jedi so he's climbed
out of the sarlacc
and his armor looks a little bit
different a little more city miles on
him nonetheless for wear
he's still got the special spurs that he
wore on his feet the jangle like clint
eastwood spurs
that was actually the big clue that made
us think that they were trying to tease
boba fett because he could have been
anybody
the whole thing with the creation of the
boba fett character is that they modeled
him after clint eastwood's man with no
name character from the spaghetti
westerns
in those movies he wore those special
spoons on his burst that would make that
sound when he walked around
that's why they did that for boba fett
during the original trilogy
but when we saw him in the episode he
was walking up to inspect fanuc shan's
body
another mercenary so it's implied that
he'd been hired by someone because boba
fett is another bounty hunter like the
mando
but when we saw that episode we didn't
yet know who the real main villain of
the season was
revealed to be moff gideon now i'm kind
of assuming that maf gideon hired boba
fett to track down baby yoda
because the mandalorian series mostly
trades on original trilogy references
and easter eggs
and giancarlo esposito confirmed my
suspicions during season 1 that they
kind of modeled the moff gideon
character to be sort of like a darth
vader figure
that's why they put him in the black
armor that's why he wears a space cape
and that's why he wields a lightsaber
aka the darksaber
and he's the main villain everyone
remembers empire strikes back that
classic bounty hunter lineup where darth
vader hires them all to go after the
millennium falcon
no disintegrations so it makes sense
they would have some similar type of
twist
on the mandalorian series with moff
gideon hiring boba fett
one of the most badass bounty hunters in
the galaxy to go after baby yoda
that just makes you excited for amando
versus boba fett standoff
there's all kinds of stuff built into
that too because part of the mandalorian
series
is explaining their creed and why his
belief system is the way it is why they
don't take their helmets off
how important their customs are to their
culture and the idea that boba fett
is kind of a fake mandalorian
technically he's just a bounty hunter
who was cloned from another person who
used to be
mandalorian but then was disowned by the
other mandalorians
django fett was at one time a
mandalorian but then sort of kicked out
of their society
so technically during attack of the
clones he couldn't call himself a
mandalorian anymore
he was just someone who walked around
wearing mandalorian armor
so the same thing is true of boba fett
he's just somebody that walks around
wearing mandalorian
armor so think about how the other
mandalorians would feel about that
they'd be really pissed off if someone
was walking around pretending to be a
mandalorian but not following any of
their customs or belief system
there's a whole lot built into that so
i'm not expecting them to cover all that
kind of story during season two that
sounds like something they could handle
during season three or season four
but number one the other obvious
question is what about the sarlacc pit
what happened after return of the jedi
will we get that backstory in flashbacks
during season two or if his role is
going to be relatively small will they
save that for season three
right now based on the way it sounds
like they're using him during season two
it sounds like we're not going to get
any of that backstory till future
seasons he'll just
show up trying to track down baby yoda
they'll have a big standoff a battle and
then that'll be it and then we'll follow
up with him during season three
the whole reason why you do him on the
mandalorian series in addition to the
fact that he wears mandalorian armor
is the fact that the mando is a bounty
hunter and the only other bounty hunter
that we know that is even more badass
than him right now in the galaxy would
be
boba fett so if anyone's going to be
able to take baby yoda
from the mando it would be boba fett now
this doesn't get into any of the ahsoka
story storyline like if ahsoka
was flying around with the mando and
baby yoda there's no way that boba fett
would have a chance so that's why i
think that a lot of these stories won't
really collide till later on
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about them doing live
action boafet with tamira morrison i
think it's
amazing that they went for him of course
they would get him to play live-action
boba fett
but i'm just really excited to see what
it looks like it sounds like we're going
to get a trailer sometime later this
year but currently they're on schedule
to release the mandalorian season 2
episodes in october
they already renewed the mandalorian for
season three and they're working on
season three episodes right now
for those of you asking whether or not
tamira morrison would also play a
version of
rex on the mandalorian because obviously
rex is another clone who's still alive
in present day
it's totally possible there was the
teaser that dave filoni posted as well
implying that they might do rex in live
action but i guess we'll see
so what'll happen is is there is a new
mandalorian documentary series that they
released i'll do a video for the first
episode of that it's on disney plus
right now they've already released two
of those episodes
while you wait for everything click here
for all my mandalorian season 2 videos
and click here for my brand new clone
wars finale video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe this is the way
[Music]